bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
24h Sénat et on commence par les suites
de l'affaire d'assaut hier le sénateur
UMP de lessonne a demandé la levée de
son immunité parlementaire devançant
ainsi la décision du Bureau du Sénat qui
doit statuer demain sur la requête des
juges ils enquêtent sur des achats de
votes présumés à corb son ville dont
Serge d'assau a été le maire et on
pensait en savoir plus aujourd'hui il
n'en est rien on va retrouver tout de
suite Tam tranui en direct de l'émicycle
bonjour th bonjour alors que s'est-il
passé tout à l'heure et bien tout à
l'heure Serge d'asso devait faire un
rappel au règlement par cette procédure
et bien les sénateurs peuvent prendre la
parole pour intervenir sur un sujet de
leur choix lié par exemple à l'actualité
ou à un débat mais finalement Serge
d'asso a renoncé à cette prise de parole
je propose d'écouter tout de suite et
bien sa très brève justifi c'était tout
à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle merci madame la Présidente
mais compte tenu du
faible personnes qui sont là je renonce
à ce à cette rle rapport au règlement
merci alors certes l'émicycle à 14h30
précise était tout à l'heure quasi vide
mais il faut aussi dire que et bien
Serge d'assau avait déjà dit tout ce
qu'il avait à dire hier en demandant et
bien sa levée d'immunité parlementaire
je rappelle que la justice a déjà
demandé par deux fois cette levée
d'immunité et que par deux fois le
bureau du Sénat lui a opposé un refus la
deuxième fois c'était il y a quelques
semaines c'était début janvier et cette
décision du Bureau du Sénat a suscité un
véritable tolé alors prochain épisode de
l'affaire d'assaut et bien demain matin
le bureau du Sénat doit à nouveau et
bien décider s'il lève ou non l'immunité
parlementaire de Serge d'assut puisque
la justice a à nouveau demandé cette
levée d'immunité alors lors de cette
réunion il y aura également une autre
question question très sensible qui va
être abordée celle du mode de vote du
bureau dans ce type d'affaire puisque
Jean-Pierre B le président du Sénat
souhaite passer et bien d'un vote à
bulletin secret à un vote à main levée
en toute transparence je vous propose
d'écouter à ce propos et bien la
réaction de Jean-Léon Dupont
vice-président centriste du Sénat il est
également membre de ce
bureau je pense qu'il peut y avoir un
vrai débat sur le
changement c'est une vraie question
c'est une question
importante que j'espère d'ailleurs
l'évolution actuelle du dossier va nous
permettre de gérer dans la sérénité
c'est pas par rapport à une personne par
rapport à un carart mais par rapport à
un vrai problème de fonctionnement
interne et je pense que nous aurons
capacité en tout cas je l'espère de le
gérer dans la sérénité soit il y a un
consensus qui se dégage et dans ce
cas-là on peut adopter certaines règles
et s'il y a pas de consensus il me
semble en tout cas de mon point de vue
qu'il faut en respecter d'autres vous
l'avez compris maintenant que Serge
dasso a demandé lui-même cette levée
d'immunité et bien les sénateurs membres
de ce bureau du Sénat espèrent pouvoir
travailler dans un peu plus de
tranquillité et bien rendez-vous demain
pour le verdict de ce bureau sur
l'immunité parlementaire de Serge
d'assut merci beaucoup Tam je vous
propose tout de suite de voir le
programme de cet après-midi sur Public
Sénat dans un instant place à la séance
consacrée une proposition de loi UMP qui
vise à renforcer les sanctions prévues
par la loi bison sur les gens du voyage
en cas de stationnement et l'c à 18h15
preuve par 3 avec Michel Sapin et on se
retrouve à 19h pour 24h Sénat le journal
tout de suite direction l'émycle
poursivre la séance bon après-midi à
tous l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de
la discussion de la proposition de loi
visant à renforcer les sanctions prévues
dans le cadre de la mise en œuvre de la
loi du 5 juillet 2000 relative à
l'accueil et l'habitat des gens du
voyage présenté par Monsieur pierre
Hérisson et plusieurs de ses collègues
je vous rappelle que nous avions
commencé l'examen de cette proposition
de loi le 12 décembre dernier dans la
suite de la discussion les articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement numéro 55
tendant à insérer un article additionnel
avant l'article
1er un amendement
55 qui le défend Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Michel oui merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
l'article 2 de la loi du 5 juillet 2000
relative à l'accueil et à l'habitat des
gens du voyage prévoit que les communes
de plus de 5000 habitants tenus de
participer à la mise en œuvre du schéma
départemental et les établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale
intéressé chargé d'assurer la gestion de
ces aires peuvent le faire soit
directement soit en confier la tâche par
convention à une personne morale droit
public ou privé le présent amendement
vise donc à professionnaliser davantage
le réseau des gestionnaires d'air
d'accueil en effet l'expérience montre
que la plupart des difficultés
rencontrées sur une heure d'accueil ont
souvent pour origine un trop faible
niveau de qualification des agents
responsables des aires qui soi agents
public ou agent du privé ou une absence
d'encadrement de proximité ou bien un
manque de reconnaissance de leur travail
si ce ne sont les trois raisons réunies
ser donc tout à fait utile de prévoir un
cycle de formation initiale ou continue
pour tous les agents d'accueil public
entrant en fonction ou en cours
d'exercice dans ces aires d'accueil car
ils ont à accueillir et je dirais à
gérer une population qui est souvent
difficile il faut bien l'avouer cette
formation devrait par exemple présenter
quelques repères fondamentaux de la
culture des gens du voyage transmettre
des informations concernant le cadre
juridique et réglementaires en vigueur
permettre d'échang sur les pratiques des
professionnels qui interviennent dans ce
domaine et mettre en lumière les
conditions d'un dialogue constructif
entre voyageurs et gadget tout en
respectant le principe de la libre
administration des collecés
territoriales il serait peut-être
également souhaitable de suivre la
recommandation du préfet Hubert de rche
qui suggère de privilégier une gestion
directe des structures plutôt qu'une
gestion déléguée pour assurer une plus
grande implication des élus en charge de
ces dossiers au sein de la commune ou de
la intercommunalité concerné voilà le
sens de cet amendement important auquel
le groupe socialiste attache beaucoup
d'intérêt je vous remercie je vous
remercie chers collègues l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
cet amendement
55 merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement qui vise à conforter la
professionnalisation des gestion de la
gestion des aires d'accueil en
instituant une obligation de formation
professionnelle continue des agents à
qui la commune délègue cette
responsabilité semble bienvenu à la
commission qui a donné un avis favorable
car de nombreuses auditions ont mis en
évidence l'importance de cette question
pour bien organiser localement l'accueil
des gens du voyage bien entendu les
situations sont très disparates il y a
de gestionnaires de d'air d'accueil qui
sont complètement professionnels et
sensibilisés à l'ensemble des
problématique mais toutefois une
formation qui permet aussi un échange de
pratique serait bienvenue et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la Commission a été
favorable à cet amendement je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le monsieur le sénateur effectivement
c'est une une question importante que
celui de la de la formation des des
personnels qui gèent les aires d'accueil
ou qui les confient d'ailleurs par
convention à à une personne publique ou
ou privée c'est effectivement de de
nature à favoriser à une meilleure
gestion de de de ces désert c'estille
comme vous l'avez souligné C c'est un
sujet qui avait été abordé dans le
rapport du préfet de rche et qui avait
fait l'objet de de travaux qui conduit
par le gouvernement qui est favorable à
l'orientation néanmoins le fait de
mettre en place un plan d'action de de
formation ne semble pas au gouvernement
relevé d'une action législative c'est
pour ce pourquoi il recommande la
sagesse sur l'amendement
55 merci Monsieur le Ministre chers vous
avez la
parole merci la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègu j'ai j'ai
bien compris là j'ai écouté le le sens
et j'allais dire que sur le fond on ne
peut être que d'accord avec cette
disposition néanmoins je rappelle que
euh notre collègue député euh en charge
d'une proposition de loi globale qui
reprend d'ailleurs une partie des
propositions que j'avais fait moi-même
en 2011 dans le cadre d'une proposition
de loi à l'issue du rapport me
semblerait mieux placé pour prendre en
considération ces discussion que la PPL
que j'ai eu l'honneur de déposer et qui
traite d'un sujet précis je pense que si
on ouvre à la discussion euh par
anticipation euh sur la PPL rebourg euh
il y a pas de raison que on n'examine
pas cet après-midi la totalité de la PPL
reinbourg et que sa place la place de
cet amendement est plutôt à venir dans
la PPL Rambourg que ici même sur la PPL
que nous examinons cet après-midi donc
nous voterons contre cette cette
amendement pas pour le problème de fond
parce qu'il n'est pas à sa place dans ce
texte merci Monsieur hérisson monsieur
le
rapporteur oui merci madame la
Présidente mon chers
collègue nous vous avons indiqué lors de
la discussion générale au mois de
décembre que justement votre proposition
de loi qui au-delà d'un certain nombre
de propositions qui étaient inopérant et
qui avait déjà dans leur esprit été
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
en tout cas des dispositions similaires
et que nous souhaitions si un texte
devait être adopté à votre initiative
qu' ne soit pas essentiellement et
exclusivement à base de sanction mais
qu'il soit équilibré qu'il envoie un
message d'inclusion aux gens du voyage
et qu'il soit précis à la fois sur les
obligations et les moyens pour les
communes de respecter leurs obligations
et en même temps de donner des moyens
aux communes de pouvoir plus facilement
lutter contre les occupations illicites
de terrain donc si votre esprit c'est
d'avoir d'obtenir à la fin de cette
journée un vote sur un texte
déséquilibré la réponse est non et c'est
bien la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons que avancer avec un texte
équilibré je vous remercie monsieur
rapporteur monsieur le ministre
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Sénateur je n'ai pas participé à à à
à vos travaux précédemment mais c'est un
sujet il se trouve que la la question de
la gestion des aires d'accueil des gens
du voyage et tout particulièrement la
question des gens du voyage c'est un
sujet que je connais un peu puisque j'ai
été pendant 11 ans maire d'une
collectivité dans lesesson président
d'une communauté d'agglomération et que
ce département de l'Essonne est traversé
assez régulièrement et assez souvent par
des des passages de de gens du voyage
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de de de
famille ou de plus grands de plus grands
rassemblements qui et je n'ai jamais
pensé à et donc à la fois comme maire
mais bien entendu encore plus comme
membre du gouvernement qu'on pouvait
traiter la question des occupations
illégales uniquement par le petit bout
de la
Loriette et que il suffisait pas de de
de de renforcer des régimes de sanction
pour que une fin le problème se règle
vous savez très bien que le problème
c'est aussi la question de l'application
de la loi baison de de 2000 c'est c'est
la question ensuite de la gestion des
aires d'accueil par par les collectivité
c'est la question de la cohabitation
entre les gens du voyage et les rivrins
bref vous avez un ensemble c'est la
question des la scolarisation des des
des enfants eux-mêmes bref vous avez un
ensemble de de dispositions qui ne
peuvent pas être comme ça traités de
manière totalement partielle je Seris t
tenté de de vous dire avec tout le
respect que je vous dois que s il y a
une PPL qui pour l'instant n'a pas
vocation d'être c'est la vôtre bon et
qu'on ne peut pas en rester uniquement à
la question des sanctions bon donc je
trouve tout assez logique qu'on puisse
aborder l'ensemble des des des
amendements qui vont permettre
d'améliorer considérablement votre texte
quoi merci Monsieur le Ministre y a-t-il
d'autres demandes d'explication de vote
je n'en vois pas je vais donc mettre au
voix l'amendement 55 présenté par notre
collègue Jean-Pierre Michel avec un avis
favorable de la commission un avis de
sagesse du gouvernement qui est
pour merci
contre merci abstention l'amendement est
adopté avant l'article 1er je suis sais
de tris amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune l'amendement
numéro 9 est présenté par Madame ben
Bassa au nom du groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente il
s'agit d'un amendement de conséquences
des amendements précédents les
amendements écolo 7 et 8 dont l'objet de
faire disparaître des textes existant la
notion de commune de
rattachement merci chers collègues 49
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel oui madame
la Présidente il s'agit d'un amendement
de cohérence de conséquence qui est le
même pratiquement que cel madame ben
Bassa même si je crois qu'il est mieux
écrit le mien ça c'est toi qui mieux écr
oui c'est moi qui mieux écrit je crois
donc cet amendement répercute dans le
Code électoral les règles de
domiciliation de l'article L 2641 du
code de l'action sociale et des familles
ainsi les personnes sans domicine stable
mentionné à l'article l2641 du code de
l'action sociale et des familles qui ont
tenu domicile soit auprès d'un Centre
communal ou intercommunal d'action
sociale soit auprès d'un organisme agré
à cet effet sont sur leur demande
inscrits sur la liste électorale de la
commune dont l'adresse figure depuis au
moins 6 mois sur leur carte nationale
d'identité au qu'il aura FNI
l'attestation d'élection de domicile
établissant leur lien avec lui depuis au
moins 6 mois si le Conseil
constitutionnel a supprimé la
disposition selon laquelle les gens du
s'inscrire dans leur commune de
rattachement après 3 ans de rattachement
ininterrompu dans la même commune
ramenant de ce fait le délai dérogatoire
de 3 ans au tit du droit commun qui
prévoit 6 mois il n'a pas invalidé le
dispositif de commune de rattachement
avec le seuil de 3 % maximum c'est
l'objet de cet
amendement piermichel sou voulez-vous
présenter le 50 rectifié dans la le 50
rectifié é également un amendement de de
conséquence mais qui répercute cette
fois non pas dans le code de l'action
sociale mais dans le code général des
impôts les règles de domiciliation de
l'article l2641 du code de l'action
sociale et des famille premier
amendement dans le Code électoral
deuxème amendement dans le Code Général
des impôt je vous remerci chers
collègues je vais donc demander à notre
rapporteur l'avis de la commission sur
ces trois
amendements merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alors l'avis de la commission est est
défavorable sur ces trois amendements
toutefois je me permet de faire quelques
commentaires d'abord sur le sens enfin
initialement ces amendements étaié
déposés parce que nous certains avaient
pour ambition d'abroger la totalité de
la loi de 69 alors peut-être faut-il
rappeler ce l'effet des des votes du
mois de de décembre la loi de 69 donc
celle qui est relative à l'exercice des
activités ambulantes et au régime
applicable aux personnes circulants en
France sans domicile et résidence fixes
avait euh dans son titre premier un
certain nombre de dispositions sur
l'exercice des activités ambulantes et
délivrance de titres de circulation
l'article 1 a été abrogé
depuis 1900 2008 depuis 2008 de manière
totale l'article 2 l'article 3 et
l'article 4 l'article 5 et l'article 6
donc en fait tout le Titre 1 a été
abrogé euh je rappelle qu'une bonne
partie de ces dispositions avaient déjà
été euh censuré par la le Conseil
constitutionnel le 5 octobre 2012 en ce
qui concerne l'article 7 euh l'article 7
indique en sur cette loi de 69 que toute
personne qui sollicite la délivrance
d'un titre de circulation prévu aux
articles précédents qui ne sont plus qui
ne seraient plus dans la loi est tenu de
faire connaître la commune à laquelle
elle souhaite être rattachée par
conséquent d'une certaine manière sans
avoir accepté et nous le regrettons euh
nous sommes un certain nombre à le
regret été l'abrogation de la loi de 69
le moteur qui permet de continuer à
faire fonctionner les articles suivants
de cette loi n'est nexiste plus puisque
toutes les dispositions concernant les
titres de circulation ne sont plus
opérationnelles je je rappelle que c'est
principalement le la notion de commune
de rattachement est des 3 % pour de 3 %
d'une population municipale qui
bénéficient d'un titre de circulation
qui peuvent être sur les listes
électorales qui n'ont pas été abrogé
alors audelà de ce que l'on peut penser
de ces deux de cette nonabrogation de
ces deux articles il est vrai que cela
peut imposer dès maintenant et ça je je
le dis à titre personnel de se poser la
question de savoir comment faire à
partir du moment où il y a plus de titre
de circulation alors la proposition de
rattacher à l'article L
2641 sur le droit à la domiciliation sur
le dans le code de l'action sociale et
des familles semble totalement opportun
et d'ailleurs euh le projet de loi
allure qui est actuellement en
discussion a introduit dans son article
212 qui complète le Code civil pour
régler les les les droits civils d'une
personne sans domicile stable par
l'élection d' domicile dans des
conditions prévues par l'article du code
l 2641 du code des familles par
conséquent il semblerait que nous
pouvons nous pourrions d'ors et déjà
donner
voter et tenir compte donc de ce qui qui
a été voté dans cette lors de la par
l'abrogation partielle de la loit de 69
en décembre nous pourrions d'ors et déjà
en tirer les conséquences et adopter me
semble-t-il l'amendement numéro 9 par
contre à partir du moment où la navette
a vocation à faire prospérer le texte et
à
l'améliorer il est clair que il faudra
se pencher sur l'avenir du reste de la
loi de 69 mais aussi il est peut-être
prématuré de modif le code général des
impôts par conséquent à titre personnel
j'aurais tendance à
inciter mes chers collègues vous inciter
à à donner un avis favorable à voter
l'amendement numéro
9 et à pour l'instant ne pas modifier le
code général des impôts estce que cette
discussion prospère au cours des des
prochaines navettes parce que ça serait
peut-être un peu prématuré mais en tout
état de cause j'attire votre attention
sur le fait qu'avec cette abrogation
partielle de la loi 69 nous sommes dans
une situation bancale et et que par
conséquent les les amendements qui
avaient été prévu ont déjà tout leur
sens je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur voulez-vous préciser
l'amendement numéro 9 vous êtes
favorable c'est clair que la la
commission a donné un un avis
défavorable aux trois amendements
simplement je dis qu'à titre personnel
contenu de l'aspect bancal de ce qui
nous reste de la de la loi 69 après le
vote du mois de décembre il me semble
qu'il est déjà opportun de prendre des
dispositions pour régler le problème de
domiciliation quand bien même dans la
loi allure des dispositions sont déjà
prévues par contre concernant le code
général des impôts et bien je propose de
s'en remettre à la suite de la
discussion parlementaire et au
prochaines navettes je suis désolé
madame la Présidente si je n'ai pas été
CLA la première fois j'espère l'avoir
été un peu plus je vous en prie Monsieur
le Ministre l'avis du Gouvernement
oui merci Madame la
présidente en ce qui concerne les ces
ces amendements et d'ailleurs peut-être
pas que on est on est actuellement sur
le le 9 le 49 et le 50 mais je crois que
je vais essayer de présenter une
position plus générale du gouvernement
sur d'autres amendements même si j'aurai
l'occasion de de revenir à savoir le 30
le 28 le 46 47 48 et 70 voilà
euh à l' instat de ce qui était prévu
dans la dans la proposition de loi
auquel monsieur le sénateur faisait
référence tout à l'heure à savoir celle
qui est été la proposition de loi dite
rimbourg qui a été euh déposée
enregistrée la Présidence de l'Assemblée
nationale en décembre 2013 le
Gouvernement est favorable à une
modification des règles de Dom
domiciliation des des gens du voyage qui
remplace le régime prévu par l'actuelle
loi de 69 par un régime reposant sur le
le le l'article L 264 à 1 T1 par contre
pardon du code de l'action sociale et
des familles cet article prévoit en
effet que les personnes sans domicile
stable etissent domicile soit auprès
d'un Centre communal ou intercommunal
d'action sociale soit auprès d'un
organisme agréé à cet effet ce
rattachement leur donne notamment accès
aux prestations sociales à la délivrance
d'une carte nationale d'identité ou
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
un tel changement du régime de
domiciliation des gens du voyage suppose
d'élargir la portée de la domiciliation
résultant de l'article 2641 du code de
l'action sociale et des familles lequel
n'ouvre pas l'accès en état actuel de la
législation à l'ensemble des droits
attachés au domicile auquels les gens du
voyage doivent avoir accès en outre il
convient de vous supprimer les
dispositions prévoyant les règles
spécifiques pour les personnes soumises
au régime de la loi de 69 et de modifier
celles qui font référence enfin il
convient de prévoir des dispositions
transitoires réglant la situation des
personnes qui aujourd'hui se voi
appliquer le régime de la loi 69 afin
d'éviter toute discontinuité dans
l'exercice de leur droit voilà le schéma
sur lequel le gouvernement entend
parvenir le Sénat n'a pas voté
l'abrogation des articles 7 à 10 de la
loi de 69 relative au rattachement en
revanche il a voté l'abrogation des
articles 2 3 et 4 et 6 qui régissent les
titres de circulation des gens du voyage
or résulte de l'économie générale de la
loi de 69 que des articles 7 et 10 ne
sont applicables qu'aux personnes qui
détiennent ou sollicitent les 10 titres
de de circulation et donc si les choses
resterai restai là il en résulterait un
certain nombre de difficultés en
particulier
l'existence de deux deux régimes qui
continueraient à coexister pour les
mêmes personnes dans bon nombre de
domaines celui de la commune de
ratachement prévu par la loi 69 qui ne
serait applicable qu'aux personnes
détentrices d'un titre de circulation à
la date d'entrée en vigueur de la loi et
celui de la domiciliation auprès d'un
CCAS ou d'un organisme agréé en outre
l'adoption de dispositions supprimant
les renvois à la loi 69 que le
gouvernement soutient également dans
leur principes et leur objet pourrait se
traduire par des incertitudes enfin
comme vous l'avez souigné monsieur le
rapporteur cette réflexion doit être
désormais conduite en tenant compte du
vote récent des des dispositions de
l'article 21 de la loi allure qui passe
en CMP d'ailleurs je crois aujourd'hui
et qui étant les effets de la
domiciliation des personnes sans domicil
stable via les CCAS pour toutes ces
raisons le Gouvernement madame la
Présidente recommandera la sagesse de
votre assemblée sur ces amendements je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre y
a-t-il des explications de vote monsieur
pierre Hérisson vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alors je sais pas si véritablement euh
euh la répétition est nécessaire mais je
voudrais pas être obligé de la faire à
chacun des amendements mais je rappelle
ici et je vous le dis euh à Monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien noté votre
intervention c'est que qu'est-ce que
nous examinons comme texte et quelle est
la situation temporaire aujourd'hui en
attendant le la proposition de loi de
notre collègue député Dominique rimbourg
qui comme je l'avais imaginé avant 2011
au moment où j'ai déposé une proposition
de loi globale dite de modernisation de
la loi baisson qui touche à l'ensemble
de la problématique des personnes qui
ont décidé de choisir le mode de vie en
itinérant dans are pays alors évidemment
on peut toujours prétexter la nécessité
d'avoir un texte équilibré mais on
partle d'un texte spécifique qui est une
PPL qui touche à un problème particulier
qui sont qui essayer de donner un signal
au désordres excessifs qui se sont
produits pendant l'été dernier pour
pratiquement l'exclusivité concernant
les grands passages sur notre territoire
alors si on part dans un texte avec les
60 amendements qui consiste à anticiper
la PPL rebourg je pense que nous aurons
les 4 heures dont nous avons besoin au
mois de février au mois de mars il y en
a pas peut-être au mois d'avril
peut-être au mois de mai peut-être au
mois de juin en espérant que finalement
la loirimbourg soit inscrite le plus
rapidement possible à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale pour qu'on puisse
entrer dans le processus d'une
discussion globale sur la problématique
de la modernisation de la loi bison de
2000 dont j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été ici
un des deux rapporteurs donc j'ai
quelques souvenirs de la loi de 2000 à
un moment donné où j'étais en en rappor
le rapporteur de la partie urbanisme et
surtout où Jean-Paul del levoir dont le
parcours n'est pas à rappeler ici mais
était le rapporteur au fond et où nous
avons ensemble avec Louis Besson posé
les fondations d'un texte qui pour la
première fois dans les lois de la
République française était la fondation
qui nous permett très progressivement
d'aller à l'abrogation de la loi de
1969 il se trouve que ceux qui ont pris
l'initiative de la question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité n'ont pas obtenu
satisfaction puisque le la demande
formulé portait sur l'abrogration totale
de la loi de 69 ils n'ont pas obtenu
satisfaction alors aujourd'hui si on
veut essayer excusez-moi du terme mais
de bricoler le la la partie abrogé sans
tenir compte de la nécessité d'un texte
sur lequel je me suis jamais caché
derrière mon petit doigt je suis et je
reste tel que je l'ai déposé dans ma PPL
de de 2011 favorable à ce qu'on annule
complètement la loi de 1969 pour pouvoir
réécrire un certain nombre de
dispositions qui concerne aujourd'hui le
le principal point de difficulté ce ne
sont pas bien sûr que les difficultés
existent mais le point principal de la
difficulté il porte essentiellement sur
la problématique des grands passages qui
pour 99 % d'entre eux sont d'origine
cultuelle qui sont organisés sur le
territoire sous forme de mission qui
utilisent des terrains qui sont certes à
mise à disposition insuffisante mais qui
aujourd'hui doivent faire l'objet d'une
prise en charge et d'une prise en compte
par l'État au même titre que les grands
rassemblements vous pouvez écrire tout
ce que vous voulez votez tout ce que
vous voulez sur un sujet sur lequel j'ai
la prétention depuis 2000 de connaître
un peu un certain nombre de choses ça
c'est certain hein madame Benbassa je
suis désolé mais j'ai un peu plus de
pratique que vous et vous savez les
associations aujourd'hui elles sont pas
forcément très tellement d'accord même
pas d'accord du tout avec ce que vous
faites depuis que vous êtes arrivés ici
et ça sur un certain nombre de bancs et
pas forcément de l'opposition je peux
vous dire je ne vous ai pas interrompu
madame Benbassa et je ne vous
interromprai jamais mais je vous dis
simplement que nous ne pouvons pas
continuer cet après-midi à examiner
amendement par amendement un texte si
j'étais à la place de Dominique vambourg
moi je serais très mécontent de ce qui
se passe cet après-midi ici parce qu'on
est en train de dénaturer et d'anticiper
un texte sur lequel il a beaucoup
travaillé il a beaucoup consulté et il a
repris une partie et j'en suis assez
fier d'ailleurs ça peut peut-être
paraître bizarre à certains mais je
pense que la concertation que nous avons
avec Dominique rimbourg sur ce sujet
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
vaut qu'onon puisse attendre monsieur le
ministre quelques semaines voir quelques
mois pour examiner un texte global et ne
pas nous laisser embarquer dans des
amendements qui certes peuvent avoir un
intérêt mais qui dénature complètement
le texte de Dominique
rbourg merci merci chers
collègues Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel
monsieur le Président peut-être monsieur
le Président de la Commission madame la
Présidente d'abord je
remercie le gouvernement d'avoir donné
un avis favorable à ses amendements
et la sagesse pour moi c'est
favorable le le Sénat est une assemblée
de Sage donc si vous vous en remettez à
la sagesse du Sénat vous aurez un vote
positif si vous en remettez à la sagesse
de l'Assemblée nationale ça peut être
différent donc revenons à des choses
sérieuses j'entends monsieur d'liger
alors c'est vrai qu' sur un sujet
important on délibère dans des
conditions difficiles puisque les
propositions de loi c'est 4 au bout de 4
He on n pas le temps de terminer on
remet ça quelques mois plus tard on
oublie ce qu'on a dit au début on
reprend au milieu très bien mes chers
collègues c'est vous qui avez réinscrit
la proposition des loi à l'ordre du jour
vous n'avez qu'à la retirer vous n'avez
qu'à la retirer vous n'avez qu'à la
retirer alors ne faites pas des grands
discours hypocrites ne faites pas de
grands discours hypocrite s'il vous
plaît à 2 mois des municipales on sait
ce que vous voulez faire ici de la
propagande c'est tout et pas du travail
juridique alors si vous si vous jugez
qu'on ne peut pas légiférer comme ça
nous en sommes d'accord retirez de
l'ordre du jour dites-le on s'en va on
passe à autre chose si c'est pas le cas
je demande qu'on vote les trois
amendements qu'on vient de
présenter merci Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Michel madame ben
bassin je suis d'accord avec Jean-Pierre
Michel écoutez vous vous connaissez
mieux que moi c'est sûr mais vouslez
enfin je sais pas vous vous lesz
pénaliser c'est qui aime bien châti bien
alors c'est ça et ben bravo bah écoutez
moi je vous conseille ne sachant rien
sur les gens du voyage et mais les ayant
auditionné longuement que vous retiriez
votre texte parce que ça fait la
deuxième fois qu'on est là et on sait
pas vous êtes d'accord pour contre et
cetera peut-être on va revenir une
troisième fois alors voilà où on vote
ces ces articles où vous retirez votre
je sais pas il faut trouver une solution
il faut c'est électoraliste monsieur
hisson vous le savez bien
vous les connaissez bien moi j'ai lu
j'ai lu vos vos écrits sur la question
vous ne disiez pas la même chose je sais
pas qu'est-ce qu'il vous arrive à
l'approche des élections hein je suis un
peu étonnée que vous ayez un double
langage sur les gens du voyage voilà
merci Madame ben bassin madame Goulet
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues moi je
voudrais dire que nous suivons la vie de
pierre Hérisson qui qui en la matière
fait autorité depuis longtemps je
n'oublie pas qu'il est venu soutenir des
cas difficiles euh notamment dans dans
mon département et qu'il est quand même
parmi les gens qui connaissent bien le
sujet par ailleurs moi qui ne le connaît
pas beaucoup je remarque simplement que
les amendements qui sont déposés sur ce
texte sont majoritairement communistes
socialistes et viennent du groupe
écologiste voilà ce qui prouve que vous
vous avez quand même avec ce texte
quelques quelques difficultés quoi qu'il
en soit euh nous voterons euh avec le
groupe UMP sur sur ce dossier merci
Madame Goulet monsieur Richard
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre moi je ne voulais pas
intervenir dans ce débat mais compte
tenu de la tournure que prennent les
événements je dois le
faire en fait de quoi s'agit-il nous
sommes mes chers collègues dans dans une
niche parlementaire UMP bien UMP dont on
sait la durée ça a été dit
bien nous avons sollicité le Sénat sur
un certain nombre d'articles très peu
nombreux comme vous l'avez vu de cette
proposition de loi qui vise à R forcer
les sanctions c'est le terme qui vise à
renforcer les sanctions compte tenu de
ce que l'on a et Monsieur hisson VI le
dire observer tout particulièrement
l'été dernier à l'occasion des grands
rassemblements bien alors Monsieur
Michel il s'agit pas de de de retirer ou
non nous posons une question simple
est-ce que oui ou non le Sénat est prêt
à renforcer des sanctions que nous
estimons absolument indispensable compte
tenu des débordements que l'on a vu
l'année passée et c'est pas POS le
problème dans sa globalité comme on le
fait avec que saisje 60 amendements dont
on sait qu'ils ne pourront pas être vu
en surtout avec la tournure des
événements dans les 4 heures de notre
niche parlementaire qui par ailleurs a
un deuxième point inscrit à l'ordre du
jour donc je peux pas accepter ça vous
votez oui vous votez non et puis et puis
voilà il suffit de nous dire si vous
voulez ou non renforcer les sanctions à
l'égard des contevenant en la matière
c'est aussi simple que cela si Monsieur
Richard la parole est au président
mzard merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je n'avais pas moi
non plus prévu d'intervenir
mais je crois qu'il s'agit d'un d'un
problème important qui revient
périodiquement moi je préside une
communauté d'agglomération qui a cette
compétence et et je m'occupe de cela
depuis de de très nombreuses années et
là le discours électoraliste ou ou
démagogique je crois qu'il fautit
rentrer dans la poche la période
effectivement nous sommes proches des
élections municipales mais après les
élection municipale il y a l'été et
l'été on va encore assister à un certain
nombre de débordements et de
comportements qui sont devenus
intolérables pour nombre de nos
concitoyens insupportables pour des
milliers d'élus et qui vont à l'encontre
d'ailleurs de la Défense et de l'intérêt
des gens du voyage tout à fait bon voilà
la réalité alors quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui la situation nous la
connaissons il y a des
collectivités je parle de ce que je
connais je préside une agglomération où
nous sommes mis totalement en
conformité avec les exigences de la Loi
ça a coûté d'ailleurs cher donc il y a
les aires d'accueil il y a une aire de
grand passage et je constate quoi c'est
que malgré le respect des obligations
légal et bien on narrive on narrive pas
à faire respecter la loi par une partie
une parti des gens du voyage il y a des
certains d'entre eux qui ne posent
jamais de problème il y en a d'autres
qui posent systématiquement des problème
et lorsqu'on respecte la loi monsieur le
ministre et bien on constate que ceux
qui commettent des débordements il y a
pas moyen
d'obtenir de des for force de l'ordre
aussi souvent des autorités
préfectorales les concours et les
décisions nécessaires pour faire
respecter la loi la réalité c'est ça la
réalité de terrain alors pouvez vous
abriter derrière toutes les grandes
déclarations dont on a l'habitude mais
la réalité de terrain c'est celle-là
alors que que vous ayez des des que vous
ayez une politique différente par
rapport aux collectivités qui ne respect
pas la loi qui n'ont pas fait
d'aménagement qui n'ont pas d'air de
grand passage tout à fait d'accord tant
pis pour eux mais au moins que pour ceux
qui respectent la loi vous donniez les
instructions nécessaires pour que la loi
soit respectée or je suis désolé de vous
dire vous ne le faites pas merci
monsieur le Président
mard la parole est au président Carle
oui merci madame la Présidente
simplement rappeler à notre collègue
Monsieur Michel que c'est c'est la
Commission qui a modifié le texte
initial de que nous avions déposé en
totale contradiction avec le gentleman
agrement qui présidait dans cette
assemblée et qui a d'ailleurs été
reconnu par le président des Sénat en
conférence des présidents qui visait à
dire que c'est le texte initial qui a
été déposé par le groupe parlementaire
qui devaitêtre étudié et débattu en
commission ça n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui je le regrette on a bien
compris les raisons qui vous amène à
faire durer ce texte pour pas que nous
le votions avant les échéances c'est une
évidence merci Monsieur car la parole
est à Monsieur Doliger
oui merci madame la Présidente je me
permet de prendre la parole parce que
tout à l'heure peut-être par erreur mais
Monsieur Michel m'a cité alors j'ais pas
pris la parole il devait seulement
vouloir parler de mon collègue hisson
mais comme c'est un sujet qui pardon
parce que silence parce que mon silence
est éloquent dit Jean-Pierre sour merci
monsieur le Président simplement pour
dire qu'effectivement si on attend mais
monsieur mzard l'a dit quelques instants
euh les échéances électorales on
traitera jamais du sujet parce que après
l'été il y a des cantonales et des
régionales et cetera et puis après on
trbar dans autres échéances donc on a
vraiment un problème sur le terrain à
régler et le président de la commission
des lois le connaît aussi bien que moi
puisque nous sommes allés voir Monsieur
Vals il y a pas longtemps pour essayer
de régler des problèmes de très grands
rassemblements de plusieurs milliers de
caravanes qui entraînent des grands
passages en permanence et que si on
n'est pas en capacité de régler le
problème alors plus tard dans sa
globalité on en sortira jamais et si
l'État ne prend pas ses responsabilités
on n sortira pas là en l'occurrence
qu'on demande c'est au moins de pouvoir
appliquer les textes et de faire en
sorte qu'on prenne un certain nombre de
dispositions urgentes et rapides pour
régler le problème mais je rappellerai
aussi dans le cadre de ce qui se passe
actuellement sur ce texte et des
amendements que j'ai connu la même mes
aventures c'était une des premières
peut-être mes aventures lorsqu'on dépose
dans une niche lorsque j'avais déposé un
texte sur les normes euh bon je suis
ravi que il est pu franchir au bout d'un
certain temps mais on a tout fait au
départ pour le bloquer de la même
manière et faire en sorte qu'il puisse
pas é utiler dans le temps imparti donc
c'était exactement la même technique
alors où c'est des techniques politiques
et à ce moment-là c'est même plus la
peine de déposer des PPL ou alors on
laisse la liberté dans un cadre
démocratique au Sénat à l'opposition de
proposer des textes il les présentent
vous en voulez pas et bien ils sont
refuser comme vous êtes majoritaire mais
je pense que bien souvent les textes que
l'on présente euh euh ont des sentiments
différents dans votre majorité et il y
en a un certain nombre d'entre vous qui
sont prêts à nous suivre c'est souvent
ce qui vous pose problème c'est la
raison pour laquelle on peut dire qu'il
y a un certain sabotage des textes qu'on
présente et je le regrette infiniment
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame
kckerman bien bah puisque tout le monde
personne n'avait prévu de prendre la
parole et que tout le monde l'apprend je
vais suivre mes collègues parce que je
crois tout d'abord qu'il est important
que sur cette question euh nous
puissions garder la sérénité des
échanges que nous avons eu en décembre
ensuite rappeler
effectivement que je crois qu'il est
important à travers cette proposition de
loi comme à travers d'autres qu'il nous
faut nous garder de toute stigmatisation
de quelques catégorie de population que
ce que ce soit et d'ailleurs c'est pour
cela que dès l'intervention générale en
décembre nous avions dit que nous ne
nous retrouvions pas effectivement dans
cette proposition de loi parce que
j'entends ce qui est dit sur le fait que
la loi n'est pas toujours respectée cert
par une minorité c'est un débat qui on
avait à peu près terminé d'ailleurs sur
sur ces échanges là en décembre mais on
sait aussi on peut renforcer les
sanctions ça ne règle pas le problème du
respect ou du non respect de la loi et
on le voit dans tous les domaines dans
celui-ci là encore comme dans d'autres
donc on a une opposition
et un échange période électorale ou pas
sur cette question et sur ce principe là
donc je rassure madame Goulet pour une
fois finalement que les écologies le
groupe écologiste socialiste et
communiste et des amendements qui
aillent dans le même sens ramène un
petit peu de réalisme aux équilibres
politiques traditionnel de de notre
République donc vous voyez c'est
finalement les choses qui se retrouvent
et puis ensuite je crois que sur tout le
reste du débat on peut en discuter tout
l'après-midi mais moi je pense que
effectivement ce que nous vivons là et
ce qui a été vécu à travers d'autres
textes et ce qui sera vécu dans les
jours qui viennent parce que finalement
les Modus vivindit du fonctionnement des
niches sont en train d'être de trouver
des dérogations sur beaucoup des des
principes hein les renvois en commission
on dépose une PPL et puis on fait des
renvois en commission à quelques
semaines également des élections on peut
aussi parler d'électoralisme euh donc je
crois que il faut peut-être mettre à
plat révisons le règlement du Sénat et
vous le savez savez notre groupe nous
avons des propositions pour que le
pluralisme que l'initiative législative
puisse être réelle exister avoir toute
cette portée donc de cela on peut en
discuter nous serons présents si vous le
souhaitez mais je vous propose quand
même mes chers collègues que pour
l'heure et pour cet après-midi nous
revenons à ce qui nous rassemble ici
même si ça peut nous diviser sur le
texte c'est-à-dire effectivement l'objet
de la proposition de loi de nos
collègues de l'UMP merci Madame
cuckerman la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
oui je je suis allé assez halluciné par
votre intervention monsieur hérisson et
par les suivantes de vos collègues je
rappelle je rappelle que nous traitons
quelques amendements qui ont juste pour
objectif de discuter de la manière dont
on doit tirer les conséquences des votes
du Sénat du mois de décembre certains
votes d'ailleurs auxquels vous avez
participé donc nous aurions pu comp tenu
de votre grande compét sur le sujet vous
entendre sur cette question précise de
ce qu'il aurait pu ce qu' les
souhaitable de tirer comme conséquence
du vote auquel vous avez participé au
mois de décembre or rien du tout
plusieurs de vos collègues de votre
groupe politique ont
parler refait une discussion générale
ayant pour simple objectif de faire
durer la discussion si vous voulez aller
sur le fond des choses si vous voulez
aller sur le fond des choses alors
travaillons sur les amendements
précisément et et et et faites-nous à ce
moment-là le le le plaisir de partager
votre connaissance du sujet sur
justement cette question de
domiciliation et pas de revenir sur le
sujet de manière générale mais vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
dit il ne s'agit pas de faire la loi il
s'agit d'envoyer un signal alors éidment
sil s'agit d'envoyer un signal
l'important c'est de taper c'est pas de
résoudre c'est de taper bon et ben non
c'est pas en tapant qu'on trouve la
solution la solution n'a de sens que
globalement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle de ce texte tel que vous l'avez
déposé la commission effectivement a
fait nombre de propositions de
modifications mais parce que si on veut
trouver une solution et je partage
totalement ce que dit le président mzard
c'est une question
urgente qui pose de vrais problème de
respect de la loi et des principes
républicains dans la mesure où un
certain nombre
de d'occupation illicite ne peuvent pas
être remises ne peuvent pas être
sanctionné c'est évident mais il n'y a
pas on a besoin et la discussion
générale la dernière fois l'a bien
souligné il faut regarder le problème
globalement alors je vais pas après vous
avoir dit qu'il fallait pas faire durer
les débats faire la même chose
simplement je vous dis il faut
effectivement résoudre le problème sur
le fond et de manière globale mais en
conclusion je n'auraai pas la cruauté de
vous dire ou de rappeler ce que vous
nous avez euh signaler en lors des
auditions préalables sur ce que vous
connaissez ce que vous savez des
dispositions que la proposition initiale
comportait et de du décalage avec la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
vous avez comme ambition d'envoyer un
signal mais vous ne voulez pas résoudre
le problème résoudre le problème c'est
autrement plus compliqué et c'est bien
pour ça qu'il y a des amendements un peu
plus techniques qui méritent d'être
abordés parce que il ne sit pas
simplement de dire on s'est préoccuper
du problème il y a un scandale on doit
répondre non c'est par la loi ici on
fait pas des communiqués de presse ici
on fait la loi et donc on fait la loi on
doit prendre les choses globalement et
en la matière vous l'avez dit dans lors
de l'audition j'aurais préféré que vous
le disiez aussi ici euh il y a
effectivement euh par rapport à la
proposition telle qu'elle était au début
un certain nombre de choses qui ne
conviennent pas et puis il faut regarder
le problème globalement donc voilà je
vous invitera plutôt à puisque le
problème est urgent et qui mérite d'être
travaillé globalement à reprendre le fil
de la discussion et à nous rappeler que
ce qui est aujourd'hui en cause là dans
dans cette discussion sur les
amendements c'est tirer les conséquences
du vote du Sénat du mois de décembre
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est au président de la commission
Monsieur S vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je voulais intervenir sur deux points
succintement premièrement il y a une
question de procédure qui est
récurrente il est clair qu'il y a
contradiction entre le principe même de
temps réserv et le droit
d'amendement parce que sur tout projet
de loi et tout proposition de loi quelle
qu'elle soit le droit d'amendement est
quelque chose d'imprescriptible que nous
défendons tous et que nous avons raison
de défendre à mon sens la solution elle
consisterait à donner plus de temps aux
propositions de loi pour qu'elles
aillent à leur terme que ce ne soi pas
des débats confinés dans des temps
réservés au détriment de ce qu'on
appelle semaine de contrôle qui compte
un certain nombre de débats très
intéressants mais qui
euh ressortisse quelquefois de ce qu'on
appelle ici ou là le
remplissage oui mais vous savez mon cher
collègue que pour changer cela il faut
désormais changer la
Constitution et c'est un sujet c'est un
sujet monsieur hérisson qui demandera
quelques débats entre nous d'ailleurs
monsieur le Président belle puisque vous
parlez de lui a pris l'initiative de
nous consulter très prochainement sur ce
sujet mais c'est une contradiction qui
est inhérente on ne peut pas accuser des
parlementaires qu'il soi d'un côté ou de
l'autre de faire usage du droit
d'amendement ce serait nous détruire
nous-même ensuite je remarque qu'il y a
quand même de nombreux cas où des
propositions ont été votées dans le
casadre de temps réservé à l'initiative
des uns et des autres je signale à
Monsieur le Ministre que quelques-unes
sont d'ailleurs en souffrance à
l'Assemblée nationale je pense à une
proposition de loi votée à l'unanimité
sur les prérogatives du juge français
par rapport à la Cour pénale
internationale qui a été voté à
l'unanimité ici et j'en profite pour
dire un mot d'une proposition de loi que
nous avion écrite à la suite des États
généraux du Sénat avec Jacqueline Gouro
sur les conditions d'exercice des
mandats locaux et qui compte un certain
nombre de dispositions qui concernent
les premières semaines et même la
première séance des conseils municipaux
question d'indemnité en particulier
d'exercice
concrets de la des fonctions électives
et cela a été adopté deux fois au Sénat
une fois à l'Assemblée il suffirait
monsieur le ministre de l'inscrire à
l'Assemblée nationale pour que cela
s'applique personne ne comprendrait que
ça ne s'applique pas au début de la mise
en place des prochains conseils
municipaux pour ce qui est pour ce qui
est du du fond maintenant monsieur
hérisson dont chacun connaît et salue la
connaissance du sujet je tiens à le
faire à mon tour il est venu dans notre
département on a eu l'occasion ensemble
d'aller visiter
les gens du voyage lors d'un grand
rassemblement bien
euh la question des grands
rassemblements se pose éric d'liger a d
a dit à juste titre que nous avons été
reçu par Monsieur Manuel Vals ministre
de l'Intérieur il y a quelqu il y a pas
longtemps au mois de janvier et qu'il a
pris l'engagement clair et public que
les prochains rassemblement
d'été n'aurait pas lieu sur le terrain
de neoie contenu que nous accueillons
dans le département d' loirée un grand
rassemblement chaque année au printemps
et que de demander à la même commune de
accueillir un autre grand rassemblement
de ou 3 mois après c'est demander aux
élus et mettre les gens dans des
situation extrêmement difficile donc moi
je tiens à remercier Monsieur le
Ministre publiquement puisqu'il a pris
cet engagement naturellement cet
engagement quel conséquence a-t-il il a
comme conséquence qu'il faudra exercer
le pouvoir régalien de l'État pour
définir une fois sur tout pour toutes
deux ou trois terrains en France qui
seront définis par l'État et par lui
seul comme les terrains qui
accueilleront les grands rassemblements
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution
il y aura de toute façon des pressions
des protestations des remarques et
cetera mais cela fait partie de la
fonction régalienne de l'État et je suis
persuadé que la promesse sera tenue de
même je tiens à rendre acte monsieur le
rapporteur pierv
lecte que Jean yy lecte je confonds avec
un autre collègue que dans l'article 6
tel qu'il a été modifié se trouve
augmenter le pouvoir régalien de l'État
par rapport non pas au grands
rassemblements mais au grands passages
qui sont souvent la conséquence des
grands rassemblements tout marche
ensemble je crois que c'est absolument
nécessaire nous sommes pour la
décentralisation mais il y a des sujets
par rapport auxquels l'État républicain
doit prendre à 100 % ses responsabilités
en l'affaire je tenais à le dire pour
souligner le travail du ministère de
l'Intérieur et dire qu'à cet égard il me
paraît sage qu'il y ait des dispositions
clair comme celle qui figure dans cet
article 6 et qui si ce texte n'était pas
adopté figurerait je le suppose dans une
la future loi euh dont on parle bien
qu'elle ne soit pas à l'ordre du jour
merci monsieur le Président vous avez la
parole monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente non
je voudrais pas pas allonger les les les
débats pour mais néanmoins monsieur
Risson j'ai j'ai cru comprendre que vous
souhaitiez légiférer dans l'urgence par
rapport à un problème important c'est un
problème important je crois que personne
ne l' niit et le président de de la
commission des lois rappele que vous
aviez été reçu par le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui je crois n'a pas
contesté connais bien ces sujets et n'a
pas contesté en rien le fait qu'il
fallait que que l'on règle le problème
mais là encore faut pas confondre
peut-être que ça change par rapport à au
au aux dernières années oou tout d'un
coup lors qu'il y avait un problème à
régler dans l'urgence on faisait une loi
dans l'urgence on se préoccuper de
savoir si elle était applicable après si
elle prenait en compte la globalité du
problème là vous êtes bien conscient
qu'actuellement il y a un travail du
gouvernement non seulement du ministre
de l'intérieur mais actuellement
également de la ministre de l'Égalité
des territoire et et du logement pour
pouvoir essayer de fournir une réponse
globale puisque vous savez trè très bien
que sur la la question de l'accueil des
gens du du voyage qu'il s'agisse des
grands rassemblements ou ou de l'accueil
de de de rassemblement plus plus petit
il y a
aussi la question de du fait que
l'ensemble des collectivités ne
remplisse pas leurs obligations
vis-à-vis de la loi bon et qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une position équilibrée le
gouvernement je crois n'a aucun problème
sur le fait que pour les maires qui
respectent la loi il faut il faut
pouvoir y compris peut-être même
renforcer leur p voir de façon à ce
qu'on puisse aller plus vite mais que ça
doit se situer dans un texte global
équilibré qui prend en compte la
globalité du problème voilà la position
du gouvernement et pas dans l'urgence
électorale parce que je je vois bien
aussi parce que nous faisons nous sommes
dans une assemblée certes de SAG mais
qui fait aussi un peu de politique bon
et que nous sommes quand même dans une
période un peu particulière actuellement
je sens que vous voulez lancer certains
messages très particulierers en ce qui
concerne un sujet qui peut-être sensible
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre il
n'y a plus de demande de parole je vais
donc ah non Monsieur Michel vous vous
êtes déjà exprimé je je suis désolée je
suis désolé monsieur Michel j'ai refusé
la parole à Monsieur
hérisson vous retireer vos
amendements demande de scrutin public
pour ne pas allonger la séance et qu'on
pense à droite que nous faisons tout
pour que ça ne vait pas voté non non non
mais elle a pas la parole euh madame
j'ai été saisie doncune demande de
scrutin public par le groupe écologiste
sur l'amendement numéro 9 je vous
rappelle que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable et l'avis du Gouvernement
est sagesse il va donc être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants le retirez vous le retirez ah
bon ben très bien la demand la demande
vous retirez la demande très bien donc
on va procéder à un vote normal donc je
mets au voix l'amendement numéro 9 avis
de la commission défavorable avis du
gouvernement sagesse qui est pour voter
l'article l'amendement numéro 9 qui est
pour je vous remercie qui est
contre il est
adopté bien les deux autres tombes de de
toute façon Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Michel je suis désolé madame vbassa je
n'avais pas je ne vous avais pas entendu
alors nous arrivons à l'article à
l'amendement numéro 28 un article
additionnel avant l'article 1er du
groupe CRC madame kckerman vous le
présentez oui merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues cet amendement est
un amendement de cohérence avec
l'amendement que nous avions présenté
qui visait à supprimer la loi du 3
janvier 1969 relatif l'exercice
d'activité ambulante et au régime
applicable aux personnes circulant en
France sans domicile ni résidence ni
résidence pardon fixe dans l'état
d'esprit que j'évoqué tout à l'heure et
d'éviter les amalgames notre notre
amendement a malheureusement été rejeté
en séance publique le 12 décembre
dernier nous déplorons car comme je vous
l'ai expliqué cela fait plusieurs
siècles qu'il existe en France un régime
spécifique pour ce que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui les gens du voyage il aurait
donc été opportun de profiter de ce
débat public pour envoyer un fort aux
personnes concernées les réglementations
français successives spécifiques aux
gens du voyage ne se sont pas contenté
de singulariser des citoyens français
qui ont simplement choisi un mode de vie
différent mais elles ont au fil des
temps créé des outils pour contrôler
leurs mouvements et leurs activités avec
des sanctions et amendes spécifiques en
cas de manquement aux règles et dictées
elles ont également abouti au titre de
circulation dont nous avons débattu
précédemment fortement décrié aussi bien
par les associations que par la Alde le
Comité des Nations Unies pour
l'élimination de la discrimination
raciale la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme cette
loi de 1969 doit être abrogée afin que
le droit commun puisse s'appliquer à
tous de la même
manière merci chers collègues je vais
demander l'avis du notre rapporteur
l'avis de la
commission merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègu
sur l'amendement 28 la commission a
donné un avis défavorable elle a donné
donné un avis pardon elle a donné un
avis
défavorable un peu comme sur l'article
50 que vous avez fait tomber madame la
Présidente peut-être de manière un petit
peu audacieuse puisque c'était vraiment
un sujet un peu différent sur le code
général des impôts mais mon mon ma
position personnelle sur ces deux c'est
un peu que c'est pas la peine de tout
faire d'un seul coup il y a beaucoup de
de dispositions dans dans dans dans cet
article alors qu'on a déjà dit que le le
la loi de
69 n'avait pas été totalement abrogé qui
avait besoin d'un d'un travail de fond
sur l'ensemble de ces conséquences donc
la position de la de la commission elle
est défavorable et à titre personnel je
propose plutôt de continuer la
discussion sur le sujet plutôt que de de
de de prendre tout de suite une décision
donc voilà la position de la Commission
et et mon avis sur cette proposition
madame
tuerman merci monsieur le rapporteur les
la rédaction des deux amendements
n'étaient pas compatibles je vous le
confirme bien donc je vais demander
l'avis de Monsieur le Ministre
minist merci Madame la Président je vais
pas m'étendre puisque j'ai rappelé tout
à l'heure la la position du du
gouvernement sur une série de
d'amendements sachant que nous
partageons l'objectif de de l'auteur de
l'amendement qui tente à supprimer les
règles appliqué spécifiquement aux gens
du voyage en vertu du régime de la
commune de rattachement qui est prévu
par la loi de de 69 et à supprimé les
références de ce régime voilà cependant
comme je le soulignais tout à l'heure à
monsieuron il faut que ça s'incrivent
dans un ensemble cohérent qui offre aux
gens du voyage une domiciliation leur
permettant d'exercer l'ensemble de leur
droit ce que la présente proposition de
loi je l'ai rappelé tout à l'heure dans
son état actuel ne ne garantit pas en
outre en ce qui concerne l'amendement
lui-même les modifications proposées ne
paraissent pas les plus adaptés en effet
ce sont les dispositions mêmes visées
par cet amendement et non pas seulement
la mention à la loi de 69 qu'il
conviendrait de de supprimer et donc le
Gouvernement s'en remet à la sagesse de
votre assemblée
positif monsieur Monsieur
Michel merci Monsieur le le ministre y
a-t-il de demande d'explication de vote
il n'y en a pas je vais donc mettre au
voie l'amendement 28 qui a été présenté
par notre collègue cuckerman un avis
défavorable de la commission un avis de
sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
voter cet
amendement qui est contre
il y a un doute il y a un doute donc on
va recommencer qui est pour voter cet
amendement qui est pour
oui je pense qu'il vaut mieux vous lever
c'est mieux parce que c'est limite
voilà
15 15 15 15 15 voilà qui est
contre il n'est pas
adopté nous arrivons avant l'article 1er
un amendement 46 qui est présenté par
notre collègue Jean-Pierre
Michel merci merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais dire très nettement à
Monsieur richichard tout à l'heure vous
m' pas donné la parole vous avez eu
raison il faut parler avec
vérité nous sommes contre Monsieur
Richard contre une proposition de loi de
Monsieur
hérisson qui était je dirais une petite
queue de sa proposition de loi globale
qu'il avait déposé en juillet 2011 qui
prenait le problème dans son intégralité
nous sommes contre le fait de voter
comme ça une augmentation des sanctions
sans
sans regarder le reste du problème car à
quoi servirait-il d'ailleurs d'augmenter
des sanctions alors qu'aujourd'hui elles
ne sont pas appliqué et c'est vrai que
la monsieurisson c'était uniquement cela
sur cela nous sommes contre c'est la
raison pour laquelle la commission des
lois à la demande d'un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui ont déposé des
amendements a étendu
le champ de cette proposition de loi
tout à l'heure monsieur hisson nous dit
mais il faudrait faire une concertation
avec la proposition de loi de monsieur
rembourg qui a été déposé nous trouvons
des plages de de nous nous retrouvons
très bien mais c'est pour ça qu'à ce
moment là j'ai dit et bien retireer le
texte que vous avez inscrit aujourd'hui
et revenons plus tard lorsque Monsieur
rbour aura fait discuter sa proposition
de loi ce n'est pas le cas donc nous
continuons et nous continuons en
examinant le problème dans S intégralité
donc l'amendement que je propose
aujourd'hui aligne les personnes sans
domicile table qui ont élu domicile soit
auprès d'un Centre communal ou
intercommunal d'action sociale soit
auprès d'un organisme agréé à cet effet
sur le droit commun en ce qui concerne
le lie d'exercice de leur droit civil
c'est-à-dire là où ils ont leur
principal établissement comme le prévoit
l'article 102 du code civil l'expression
dooit civil désigne l'ensemble
prérogative attaché à la personne
comprend leur droit au respect de la vie
privée de la vie familiale au respect du
domicile de sa correspondance le droit à
l'image le droit d'aller venir le droit
à la liberté de penser d'expression de
conscience de religion le droit à la
liberté de réunion ainsi que le droit au
mariage et celui de fonder une famille
le plan plriannuel de lutte contre la
pauvreté pour l'inclusion sociale adopté
le 21 janvier 2013 prévoit explicitement
des mesures de simplification des
procédure de domiciliation et de
remobilisation des préfets chargés de
coordonner l'action des structures pour
la domicalisation il précise que les
préfets des départements sous la
coordination du préfet de région et en
lien avec notrec territorial et les
acteurs associatifs établiront un schéma
de domiciliation ce schéma doit définir
une couverture territoriale complète et
un assurer un suivi annuel ces
orientations doivent également prendre
en compte la spécificité de la
domiciliation pour l'aide médicale
d'État de la domiciliation des
demandeurs d'asile pour qui la
domiciliation représente une étape
essentielle et obligatoire de la
procédure d'asile ainsi que celle des
gens du du voyage pour lesquels un accès
aux prestation sociales et règ juridique
et particulièrement difficile c'est
pourquoi nous proposons d'adopter cet
amendement ce qui s'inscrit dans le
prolongement de ce plan je vous remercie
Monsieur Michel l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur cet
amendement l'avis de la commission est
est
défavorable les dispositions qui sont
prévu vu sont
satisfaits dans dans dans leur esprit
par ce qui devrait être inclus dans le
projet de loi allure qui est en fin de
de discussion parlementaire donc ce
n'est peut-être pas la peine de
compléter les dispositions qui sont déjà
prévues et qui pour SR seront adoptées
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre la viis
du gouvernement
oui merci madame la Présidente oui comme
vient de le dire le le le rapporteur
effectivement il peut y avoir le
Gouvernement partage votre avis sur
cette question effectivement il y a une
disposition de du projet de loi allure
qui a été voté dans les mêmes termes par
les deux chambres qui a le même objet
qui repose sur une rédaction qui est
plus s juridiquement notamment parce
qu'elle a été approuvée entre autres par
le Conseil d'État aussi le gouvernement
propose de s'en tenir à cette
disposition de la loi allure et donc
vous demande le retraite de cet
amendement sinon l'avis sera
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur hisson
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord euh je dirais à
l'adresse de Monsieur Michel et au nom
de la courtoisie s'il pouvait utiliser
un autre terme pour définir ma
proposition que une queue de je sais pas
quoi ce serait bien euh mais il est pas
obligé de le faire et puis je ferai pas
un rappel au règlement pour ça euh
simplement pour pour dire que si on
continue avec ce gen genre de type je
rappelle que ceux qui ont saisi le
Conseil constitutionnel l'ont fait avec
un motif tout à fait intéressant c'était
la suppression de la loi de 69 si on
commence à réécrire des amendements qui
redonnent un statut particulier au gens
du voyage alors peut-être que personne
n'a pris le temps de lire les deux
rapports successifs que j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire entre 2006 et 2010
sur un titre qui me paraissait
intéressant c'était ver Stu le plus
proche possible du droit commun on
commence à réécrire qu'ils ont droit à
ceci qu'ils ont droit à cela c'est qu'on
nadmet pas que ce sont des citoyens de
la République française à part entière
et là-dessus je pense que c'est pas le
lieu dans ce texte de redébattre ou de
débattre de quelque chose d'aussi
important et puis enfin je me permettrai
de vous dire que nous sommes en
concertation en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne avec Dominique rimbourg depuis
des mois que sa PPL elle est prête
depuis le mois de septembre qu'on nous a
annoncé qu'elle serait inscrite au
printemps je vous rappelle que c'est
dans le courant du mois de mars le début
du printemps et qui serait peut
peut-être intéressant que l'on puisse
débattre il aurait été intéressant de
débattre de la du texte global avant les
élections municipales parce qu'on était
pas obligé de le faire dans l'urgence
mais en tout cas il y aura une certaine
urgence à débattre du texte de Dominique
rimbourg et de faire la navette avant
l'été prochain parce que les difficultés
qui proviennent pratiquement
exclusivement de des grands passages
mérite en tout cas d'appliquer du mieux
possible plus vite possible l'article 6
qui consiste à dire que comme pour les
grands rassemblements qui concernent
plusieurs milliers de de caravanes et
qui 20 jusqu'à 20 ou 25000 personnes qui
sont parfaitement organisé par les
services de l'État et ce queles que
soient les majorités et depuis des
années et je le diraiis ici queles que
soient les majorités l'État et le
ministère de l'Intérieur organisent
parfaitement les grands rassemblements
dans notre pays il y a rien à redire
tout ce qu'on demande dans l'article 6
c'est qu'il prenne également parce qu'il
en a la capacité il en a les moyens il
en a la comp compétence les grands
passages qui je le rappelle sont
prescrits dans le cadre d'une circulaire
et non pas d'un texte de loi et qu'on
demande tout simplement que l'État fasse
pour les grands passages ce qu'il fait
pour les grands rassemblements et le
problème sera pratiquement réglé ensuite
nous reprendrons notre cheminement à
caractère social et économique de la vie
de personnes qui dans notre pays ont
choisi de vivre de manière itinérante
c'est ça le problème et je pense que là
on est en train de partir dans sous un
prétexte des équilibre dans un texte qui
n'a rien à voir avec la PPL que j'ai
déposé puisqu'il s'agit et je le
répéterai toujours de donner un signal
avant l'été prochain pour que le bazar
de l'été prochain ne se de l'été
précédent pardon ne se reproduise pas
l'été prochain c'est ça dont il s'agit
pour le reste je vous assure qu' on ne
traite pas d'un sujet qui veut aller
vers le droit commun pour plus de 400000
de nos compatriotes uniquement avec des
textes en s'opposant ou en se jetant les
assiettes à la figure c'est une insulte
que nous faisons auj du
voyage
merci Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel vous
êtes sollicité par le ministre pour un
retrait présidente d'abord je voudrais
dire à Monsieur hisson que j'ai le plus
grand respect pour lui et que ce n'était
pas péjoratif je voulais dire que cette
prop de loi était un tout petit morceau
d'une are plus importante c'est tout
deuxièmement ce qui est une insulte au
gen du voyage c'est de prévoir
l'aggravation de sanctions pour eux sans
prévoir tout ce qui devra aller a tour
ça c'est vraiment troisièmement madame
la Présidente contte tenu de ce qu'a dit
monsieur le rapporteur et monsieur le
ministre je retire l'amendement 46 je
vous remercie chers
collègues avant l'article 1er nous
arrivons à l'article à l'amendement 47
vous le présentez Monsieur Michel oui
madame la Présidente cet amendement
supprime les conditions spécifique
imposer aux gens du voyage et Monsieur
hérisson sera satisfait puisquil nous a
dit que c'était des citoyens comme tous
les autres qui devent traité sur un pied
de stricte égalité républicaine ce n'est
pas le cas ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est
pas le cas donc nous voulons supprimer
toutes les conditions spécifiques en ce
qui concerne le versement des
prestations familiales afférant un
enfant soumis à l'obligation scolaire
pour les aligner sur le droit commun ça
je crois que c'est respectueux des gens
du voyage je vous remercie chers
collègues l'avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission est
favorable et je je dirais à titre
personnel que même si je comprends
totalement la position et la proposition
de Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel de faire
en sorte que les gens du voyage sur ce
sujet aussi viennent dans le droit
commun c'est un exemple par rapport à
tous les autres dispositions où j'ai
plutôt incidé à la prudence tout en
disant voilà l'abrogation de la loi 69
va conduire à un certain nombre de
choses mais peut-être que
compenu de la manière dont on examine
les choses il peut-être pas né
nécessaire de de tout traiter
aujourd'hui sur la question de de
l'obligation scolaire puisqu'il s'agit
ça he il s'agit d'un amendement qui
supprime l'obligation de justifier pour
les personnes sans domicide fixe l'ASSÉ
l'assiduité des enfants soumis à
l'obligation scolaire pour prétendre aux
prestations familiales je partagerai
votre bien entendu votre position
toutefois le rapport desrache souligne
combien il est important de renforcer
l'éducation
présentielle des enfants et en
particulier des jeunes filles pour
favoriser leur leur intégration par
conséquent cette question même si euh
euh les principes républicains
obligerait à être d'accord avec vous il
me semble que sur ce sujet aussi afin de
ne pas contrarier les efforts de
scolarisation qui sont absolument
nécessaire pour pour les enfants des des
gens du voyage euh il je j'attire
l'attention sur les conséquences que
pourra avoir cette la la l'adoption de
cet amendement sans autres disposition
favorisant et s'assurant de l'assiduité
scolaire c'est la raison pour laquelle
aussi à titre personnel je je ne voterai
pas cet amendement je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre
oui madame la la présidente monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur le le gouvernement
va recommander la la sagesse et vous
allez vite comprendre pourquoi puisque
bon le Gouvernement partage l'objectif
poursuivi par vous-même tendant à
supprimer les règles spécifiques
applicables au seul gen du voyage pour
le versement des prestations familiale
afférente à un enfant soumis à
l'obligation scolaire il se trouve
simplement que ces règles ne résultent
pas simplement de l'article
l131-3 auquel vous faites référence du
code deséducation mais également de
l'article
l552-5 du code de la sécurité sociale et
donc il ne suffit pas de supprimer à
l'article l131 3 du Code de l'éducation
le renvoie à l'article 552 du code de la
sécurité sociale il conviendrait aussi
de supprimer et l'article du code de
l'éducation et celui de la sécurité
sociale merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est au président
mard merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je je je
comprends la la motivation de notre
collègue Jean-Pierre Michel mais je
crois qu' il est des messages qui sont
dangereux même quand l'intention est
bonne lorsque l'on gère les questions
d'accueil des gens du voyage on se rend
compte et nous le savons enfin tant que
nous pouvons encore exercer des
fonctions exécutives d'élus locaux nous
savons ce que c'est et bien aller euh
s'occuper des gens du voyage et
constater que la question de
l'illetttrisme ne serait pas fondamental
c'est une méconnaissance absolue du
problème nous avons un besoin impératif
de renforcer la scolarisation
l'apprentissage de la lecture de
l'écriture pour les gens du voyage c'est
cet impératif parce que c'est c'est un
des problèmes essentiels fondamentaux
pour ne pas dire un problème primordial
bon moi j'ai essayé de de faire en sorte
queon ait une école sur place même si
c'est assez contraire au au principe
républicain de la même école pour tout
le monde bon pour qu'il y ait au moins
l'apprentissage la lecture on peut avoir
un avis différent c'est l'expérience qui
euh nous a fait plutôt choisir cela mais
vraiment si nous n'avons pas les moyens
de pousser euh ces les parents à
scolariser les enfants parce qu'il y a
quand même aussi chez gens du voyage de
plus en plus de
sédentarisation au cours de l'année hein
il faut quand même dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont hein il y a du
grand passage il y a de l'itinérance
mais il y en a beaucoup qui sont
semi-sédentarisés voir plus et bien si
nous ne sommes pas capables de pousser à
la scolarisation nous manquons à nos
devoirs républicains et il y a des
messages qu'il ne faut pas passer
merci monsieur le Président mard
monsieur
hérisson simplement rappeler que sur le
plan pratique euh en fait cet amendement
je comprends le le fondement je je
partage un certain nombre de choses qui
ont été dites ici et surtout ce que
vient de dire Jacques mzard mais
n'oublions pas que ils ont la possib les
enfants les parents ont la possibilité
d'inscrire les enfants au knned et je
voudrais saluer à ce moment précis de
nos débats le travail remarquable qui
sont faits par les les personnes qui
s'occupent du knnet puisque plus de
10000 enfants des gens du voyage sont
inscrits à cette instruction par
correspondance et qu'il suffit de cette
inscription donc aujourd'hui il est pas
nécessaire de prendre la non plus des
dispositions particulières puis je
rappellerai encore une fois que
franchement vous êtes en train de me
donner raison sur le fait qu'on anticipe
sur le texte de Dominique Rambourg merci
Monsieur hisson y a-t-il d'autres
demandes monsieur bas
oui merci madame le Président je ne
voterai pas cet
amendement je ne le voterai pas alors
que effectivement il se présente sous un
jour
qui peut paraître tout à fait positif si
l'on considère que la législation
actuelle induit une forme de
discrimination entre les familles mais
de mon point de vue ça n'est pas une
discrimination c'est tout simplement
tenir compte de deux situations qui sont
différentes et si l'on se prive dans
notre
législation du moyen de tenir compte de
la spécificité de la situation de ces de
ces familles pour faire en sorte que
soit
effective la menace entre guillemets de
perdre les allocations familiales en cas
de nonsolarisation de l'enfant alors on
ne rend pas service ni à ses enfants ni
à ses familles et c'est le niveau
d'éducation de ces enfants qui doit leur
permettre comme à tout enfant de France
de progresser dans l'existence qui
risque d'être compromis et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je crois que
derrière les bonnes intentions de cet
amendement on risque de d'aboutir à une
régression de l'accès à l'éducation pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux je vous
remercie chers collègues Monsieur
Michel la présidente cont tenu des
explications de Monsieur le
Ministre également parce que nous
croyons nous qu'il faut que la
concertation avec Monsieur reimbour se
fasse et nous ferons tout pour qu'elle
se fasse contrairement à vous messieurs
et donc je retire cet amendement je vous
remercie chers
collègu avant l'article 1er unamendement
numéro 48 que vous présentez chers
collègues il le reti vous le le 48 vous
le
retirez écoutez je considère qu'il est
retiré alors je retire
merci avant l'article 1er un amendement
numéro 30 qui est présenté par Madame
cuckerman mais la la loi de 69 n'ayant
pas été ayant été maintenue quo n'ayant
pas été supprimé excusez-moi je vais le
faire dans le bon sens de fait cet
amendement n'a plus lieu d'être et il
est donc retiré je vous remercie chers
collèg avant toujours avant l'article
1er l'amendement 51 Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Michel vous le
présentez il sera discuté on verra après
la concertation avec Monsieur reimbourg
à
distance comme tous les Français car ils
sont français on l'oublie quelquefois
les gens du voyage peuvent obtenir une
carte nationale d'identité ou un
passeport l'obtention de ceci est
parfois délicate en effet une des
difficultés à résoudre tient au fait que
la mention de l'adresse ne doit pas
permettre identifier le titulaire de la
carte comme un membre de la communauté
des gens du voyage outre les difficultés
rencontrées concernant les questions de
stationnement et d'habitat une partie
des gens du voyage sont confrontés à des
difficultés sociales liées à leur mode
de vie c'est la raison pour
laquelle cet amendement présente une
mesure concrète qui permettrait de
faciliter l'insertion et de lutter
contre les discriminations et qui
consisterait à revoir la délivrance des
tytres d'identité et de façon plus
générale les documents administratifs
c'est ce que propose cet amendement il
convient de s'assurer que toute mention
sans domicile fixe soit banni des cartes
d'identité passeport permis de conduire
carte grise délivré au gens du voyage je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission est
défavorable toutefois à titre personnel
je voterai cet amendement et je le
voterai avec une grande conviction cont
tenu de d'observations que j'ai j'ai pu
faire sur cette question parce
qu'effectivement dès lors que il y a la
possibilité de déduire que telle ou
telle personne appartient à la
communauté des gens du voyage il y a des
discriminations qui s'en suivent et ces
discriminations sont à la fois mauvaises
pour les personnes qui en sont victimes
mais pour l'ensemble de la société je
donne un exemple l'impossibilité pour
une grande partie de des personnes qui
ont de telle carte d'identité de
disposer de d'une assurance automobile
et ça c'est un problème pour euh
l'ensemble de la société ou bien à des
prix complètement impossibles et par
conséquent à partir du moment où il ça
peut être résolu de cette manière-là et
que ça ne n'empêche aucune ça ne nuit en
rien il me semble que nous pourrions
adopter cet amendement merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre l'avis
du Gouvernement sur cet amendement 51
oui merci madame la
Présidente vous savez effectivement que
si les les gens de voyage sont sont de
nationalité française ils peuvent donc
comme tout citoyen demander la
délivrance d'une carte nationale
d'identité pour justifier de cette
identité dans toutes les démarches de la
de la vie courante ou lors des du
contrôle du passage aux frontières
celle-ci est délivrée sans condition
d'âge par les préfets et sous-préfets à
tous Français qui ont fait la demande
dans l'arrondissement dans lequel il est
domicilié à sa résidence ou dans lequel
il se se trouve sa commune de
rattachement
néanmoins le ministère l'intérieur pour
tenir compte d'ailleurs de ce que vous
venez de de de dire de d'autre part
d'une d'une recommandation formulée par
la la Halde néanmoins prescrit au préfet
il s'agit d'une circulaire du 27
septembre 2007 de délivrer la carte
nationale d'identité ou le passeport aux
personnes intéressant intéressé pardon
en excluant la mention de leur commune
de rattachement seul l'adresse de la
mairie de Le commune de rattachement
peut y figurer elle est inscrite alors
sous la forme suivante non prénom de la
personne et adresse de la mairie sans
qu'il soit fait mention du fait que
c'est une mriie donc sans qu'il soit
fait mention de de l'établissement cette
adresse concrétise le lien de ces
personnes avec l'administration les
services de la préfecture à l'origine de
la délivrance du titre de circulation
sont avisés de la délivrance de l'un de
ces documents voilà donc comme je vous
le disais cette cette instruction répond
aux recommandations formulées par la
Halde dans sa délibération du 17
septembre 2007 qui vise à la suppression
de la menç de la commune de rattachement
sur la carte nationale d'identité de ces
personnes on raison comme vous l'avez
souligné du caractère jugé
discriminatoire de cette indication à
l'égard d'une catégorie de de citoyens
a aussi pour objectif de conserver la
neutralité de l'adresse afin de ne pas
permettre de déterminer l'
l'appartenance du titulaire de la la
carte nationale d'identité à une
quelconque catégorie
socio-professionnelle entre autres donc
voilà si le gouvernement en partage
totalement votre avis mais il considère
qu'avec cette circulaire euh c'est votre
amendement est satisfait et donc il vous
demande le
retrait monsieur
hisson merci madame la Présidente très
rapidement monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je voudrais juste
apporter une précision à la suite de
l'intervention la dernière intervention
de monsieur le rapporteur pour dire que
euh la situation des assurances
automobiles s'est beaucoup améliorée
depuis grâce à entre autres au travail
de la Commission nationale consultative
des gens du voyage et qu'aujourd'hui une
grande compagnie d'assurance française a
bien voulu élaborer un produit qui
s'appelle assurance pour les gens du
voyage qui concerne le véhicule la
caravane en tant que habitation même si
la richesse de la langue française et
pour éviter d'appeler une caravane une
habitation ou un logement on a réussi à
définir ça tel que résidence mobile
terrestre principale alors qu'il y a un
ministre en 2004 qui au Conseil de
l'Europe a signé la reconnaissance par
la France de la caravane comme une
habitation et comme un logement et qu'on
na pas toujours pas réussi à transcrire
en droit français et en droit national
cette disposition mais sur les
assurances je voudrais tous vous
rassurer aujourd'hui une grande
compagnie euh française qui assure dans
des conditions plus que raisonnables par
rapport à la population sédentaire
l'assurance du véhicule CT elle existait
de la caravane en tant que logement on
va l'appeler comme ça mais aussi des
assurances complémentaires et que je
crois que les gens du voyage ont
maintenant la possibilité en tout cas au
moins une possibilité d'avoir un régime
de droit commun d'accès aux assurances
dans notre pays il leur restera un point
essentiel où je conseille à la majorité
de trouver des solutions parce que c'est
vous qui les trouverez c'est que
aujourd'hui lorsque les gens du voyage
veulent acheter une voiture ou une
caravane je bien dis bien acheter une
voiture une caravane ils sont obligés de
emprunter à une seule banque qui veut
bien leur prêter de l'argent au taux de
20 % et je pense que là nous avons
quelque chose à faire ensemble merci
chers collègues Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Michel vous êtes sollicité pour un
retrait des explications de monsieur le
ministre je retire cet amendement je
vous remercie chers
collègu nous arrivons avant l'article
1er toujours un amendement numéro
36 monsieur le squarnc qui le
présente merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc avec cet amendement donc on va pas
préparer l'été prochain on va faire un
plongeon dans l'hiver de la deuxème
guerre
mondiale bien avant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale les gens du voyage non dénommé
comme cela à l'époque devait déjà
détenir un titre de circulation à jour y
compris les enfants et le présenter dans
chaque commune laquelle pouvait leur
refuser le stationnement vous le savez
la dégradation des valeurs républicaines
au cours des années 30 consolida la
xénophobie ambiante le gouvernement de
Vichi s'inscrivit dans ce mouvement des
dates dramatiques jalon le parcours des
personnes appelées aujourd'hui gens du
voyage le 6 avril
1940 un décret interdit la circulation
des nomades sur l'ensemble du territoire
les nomades doivent se déclarer à la
gendarmerie ou au commissariat et sont
astreints à résidence dans les communes
du département choisies par le préfet le
4 octobre 1940 le régime de Vichy
autorise l'internement des étrangers de
racees juive et accède à la demande des
autorités allemandes d'interner les
ziganes en mars 1941 des expériences de
méthode de stérilisation de masse sont
lancé sur des femmes ziganes indignes de
reproduire dans les camps de ravetsbru
et d'uschwitz le 22 juin 1941 les digan
sont exécutés dans des camions à gaz à
culmof le 16 décembre 1942 un décret
signé himler ordonne la déportation des
ziganes vers le camp d'Auschwitz en mars
1943 1700 ziganes déportés de bialistock
sont gazés à leur arrivée le 25 mai
milzigan TCK subiront le le même funeste
sort en 1944 l'Allemagne Nazi réalise
des expériences d'inoculation de la
tuberculose à ne GAM principalement sur
les iganes 1000 iganes sont gazés et
brûlés dans le camp d'archvist au total
entre 500000 et
750000 zigan sont morts assassinés le
plus souvent gazés par l'Allemagne
hitlerienne en France 30000 entre eux
ont été internés dans les camps pourtant
ceux-ci furent parmi les oubliés du
procès de nuramber de son ouverture
jusqu'à son verdict le 1er octobre 1946
aucun cigan ne sera appelé à témoigner
les victimes Tigan du régime nazi ne
seront pas une seule fois mentionné
durant le procès de nuramber et
plusieurs pays européens continueront de
garder ces populations dans les camps
d'internement pendant plusieurs mois
aujourd'hui 68 ans après les premières
exactions nazi il serait temps nous
semble-t-il que la représentation
nationale française reconnaisse le
génocide des
C gitan c'est manouches et s rom
assassinés pour leur singularité être
des gens du voyage c'est le sens de
notre amendement je vous remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le squarnc je
vais demander sur cet amendement 36
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
sur ce type de question du rapport entre
la loi et l'histoire la commission des
lois a a toujours eu une position
identique précisant que ce type de
disposition ne relevait pas du domaine
de la loi et le le le Conseil
constitutionnel a a rapporté dans sa
décision du 28 février 2012 que elle
était dépourvu de portée normative c'est
effectivement le le rôle d'une
résolution qui existe depuis la
révolution depuis la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 de le cas
échéant prendre ce type de disposition
pour affirmer une position sur un tel
sujet alors avant de d'indiquer ma
position personnelle je dirais que je
vous rappelle je vous remercie d'abord
monsieur le sénateur de ces rappels
historique parce
qu'effectivement ce n'est pas une
déportation comme les autres c'est une
déportation qui a commencé le 18 enfin
un processus qui a commencé le 18
novembre 1939 par des assignations à
résidence du sur décision de préfet de
tout individu dit dangereux pour la
défense nationale et la sécurité
publique dont les nomades ensuite un
décret du 6 avril 40 signé par le
président Albert lebrin interdit la
circulation des nomades il signe ainsi
l'ouverture des premiers camps
d'internement ensuite sous le régime de
Vichi il y a eu une loi le le 3
septembre 1940 qui a pris des
dispositions complémentaires le 4
octobre 1940 la puissance occupante
exige par l'ordonnance l'internement des
Juifs étrangers et des tiganes le 17
novembre 1940 Vichi promulgue une loi
transférant la la surveillance des camps
d'internement au ministère de
l'intérieur par l'intermédiaire des
préfets territorialement compatant enfin
à la Libération c'est le ministre de
l'Intérieur Adrien Tixier qui adresse le
20 novembre 1944 au commissaire de la
République une circulaire au sujet des
prostitués des nomades internés dans
laquelle il explique qu'il n'est
toujours pas possible de les libérer
sans enquête préalable la circulaire est
à nouveau confirmée le 25 mai 1945 ce
n'est que le 10 mai 1946 qui est met fin
par une loi à l'internement des nomades
en la dé en déclarant la cessation du
conflit ce qui met de facto fin aux lois
d'exception qui avait été adopté tout au
cours de l'année 1940 par conséquent
effectivement cette vérité historique
elle doit être rappelée elle doit être
connue mais elle aussi malheureusement
dans les et on voit que toute cette
vérité historique elle est la
conséquence d'actes qui sont des actes
officiels de la République
malheureusement et donc la
reconnaissance elle est de fait puisque
ce sont des actes de la République et
d'ailleurs et et d'ailleurs les en terme
de de conséquen et de reconnaissance sur
le plan de dédommagement les les les les
choses on ont été faites de ce point de
vue-là c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui cette page noire de notre
histoire et la responsabilité de la
République française dans ce dans ces
internements n'est pas assez connu mais
une chose est la reconnaissance une
autre est la connaissance ce qui est
important pour la cohésion de notre
communauté nationale aujourd'hui c'est
que chacun est bien conscience de ces
événements historiqu et de la
responsabilité de la République
française et de la responsabilité de
ceux qui à l'époque avaient la
responsabilité de de conduire les
affaires de l'État mais euh euh pour les
raisons qui ont été expliquées
auparavant il s'agit à la fois de
pédagogie il s'agit de connaissance
historique et pas d'une nouvelle
reconnaissance qui n'a pas euh lieu
aujourd'hui puisque c'est des faites
historiques ce sont des actes de la
République qui malheureusement ont créé
cet état tragique euh mais euh ce n'est
pas euh euh rien ne peut changer cet
état de faê c'est la pédagogie qui doit
permettre à chaque Français d'être au
courant de cette situation et je vous
remercie d'avoir pu l'évoquer et je
crois que c'était utile de rappeler ces
événements tragiques et la place des
gens du voyage dans notre communauté
nationale je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre l'avis
du Gouvernement sur cet amendement
oui madame la la présidente on parle de
d'événements d'événement douloureux et
je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur de
d'avoir rappelé ce qui a été la
situation des des zigan durant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et tout
particulièrement sur notre sol entre
1940 et et 1946 je vais rappeler à
monsieur le rapporteur qui sont rentrés
dans une querelle historique il me
semble que qu'un président de de la
République a bien rappelé que ce n'était
pas la République mais l'État français
qui avait commis ses actes à cette
époque là je me permet de le dire sans
ouvrir de nouveau le débatant et après
malheureusement voilà mais je je tenais
quand même le préciser je crois que donc
il effectivement monsieur le sénateur il
était important dans cet hémicycle de
rappeler ce qui s'est passé à cette
période
néanmoins nous sommes enfin vous êtes en
train de de de faire la loi et il se
trouve que cet amendement n'a pas de
portée normative bon et et que comme
vous le savez le le Conseil
constitutionnel est de plus en plus
intransigent face aux dispositions qui
sont dépourvu de porter normative dans
les dans dans les lois il a d'ailleurs
appel récemment dans une décision du 28
février 2012 à propos de la loi visant à
réprimer la contestation de l'existence
des génocides reconnu par la loi qu'une
disposition législative ayant pour objet
de reconnaître un crime de génocide ne
serait en elle-même être revêue de la
portée de normative qui s'attache à la
loi voilà donc je cette disposition si
elle était adoptée votre amendement
serait contraire à la Constitution et
donc le gouvernement ne peut être que
défavorable quoi je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre bien la parole est
à Madame
Benbassa merci madame la Présidente euh
écoutez en tant qu' historienne je pense
que ce n'est pas au
législateur de décider qu'est-ce qui
relève du génocide qu'est-ce qui relève
d'un meurtre de masse euh c'est vrai que
les gens du voyage et les cigans n'ont
pas eu leur nurber donc ça n'a pas été
reconnu officiellement euh je ne suis
pas non plus pour que les les génocides
soient reconnus dans les prêtoires donc
il serait opportun de laisser euh de
laisser cette question aux historiens et
de ne pas nous faire de l'histoire ici
puisque ce n'est pas notre rôle en
revanche je serais symboliquement pour
qu'il y ait une résolution afin qu'on
puisse discuter de ce sujet dans les
écoles qu'on puisse faire rentrer
progressivement euh ce ce meurtre de
masse ou génocide dans les livres
scolaires et cette résolution serait
très bienvenue j insiste mais mais pas
voter par amendement d'ailleurs ça
aurait moins de de force qu'un qu'une
résolution un moment consacré à discuter
de cette question dans
l'hémicycle je vous remercie madamebassa
madame
prince
en 2008 la Haute autorité de lutte
contre les discriminations et pour
l'égalité la Alde avait alerté les
pouvoirs publics sur les discriminations
dont été victimes les gens du voyage en
y associant des recommandation celle-ci
visa à rétablir une égalité de
traitement à l'égard de cette population
qui subit aujourd'hui des discrimination
résultant du comportement individuel
mais aussi des textes en vigueur
plusieurs témoigne de l'ancienneté de la
défiance envers un peuple au mode de vie
et à la culture différent une loi
imposée en 1912 une réglementation
spécifique d'exception instituant
notamment un carnet anthropométrique
d'identité ils ont été les premiers à
subir affichage administratif le 6 avril
40 un décret loi interdit la circulation
des nomades sur l'ensemble du territoire
métropolitain et leur imposa une
résidence forcée sous la surveillance de
la police et de la gendarmerie ainsi ils
ont été particulièrement visés durant la
deemme Guerre mondiale en Allemagne la
politique anti-tigane a été intégrée à
la politique raciale des nazis comme il
suffisait d'avoir un grands-parents dit
Tigan pour être concerné des familles
mixtes et tiganes ont subi stérilisation
forcée détenenstions en cour de
concentration ou
déportation en France une ordonnance
allemande a exigé dès le 4 octobre 1940
leur internement dans des camps
administrés et surveillé par les
autorités françaises dans chaque
département les préfets ont demandé à la
gendarmerie de recenser puis de
regrouper les nomades et de les
surveiller devant l'arrivée massive des
nomades les camps ont dû rapidement
s'agrandir jusqu'à permettre au plus
grand le camp de montreil Bell en mé
Loir de recueillir 108 internés en août
1942 plusieurs actions ont déjà été
menées en ce sens comme cell conduite
par un collectif d'association en 2010
l'année consacrée à la mémoire de
l'aternement des tiganes en France
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
parrainé par le cinéaste Tony gatliff
elle a permis de sensibiliser un large
public en mlant commémoration et
information de la même façon une
stratégie
interministérielle a été développée pour
permettre de donner un éclairage nouveau
à ces événements néanmoins la
reconnaissance par la France de
l'atterernement des nomades entre 40 et
46 apparaît comme un un élément
essentiel du travail sur l'identité
mémoriel cette évolution sur le plan de
la mémoire pourrait par ailleurs faire
progresser la promotion de la culture
Tigane en complément des travaux menés
conjointement par le ministère de la
Culture et la fnsat gens du voyage c'est
la Fédération Nationale des Associations
solidairirees d'action agrittigane et
les gens du voyage
notamment chers collègues la parole est
à pierre
Hérisson merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
bon j'ai bien entendu tout ce qui a été
dit ici mais euh comment traiter un
sujet avec un amendement une catastrophe
du 20e siècle 700000 morts dans les
camps de concentration uniquement pour
les ziganes est-ce que l'on peut venir
comme
ça dire les choses alors moi je crois
que il serait mieux de retirer cet
amendement et puis en tout cas nous ne
voterons pas ce texte parce que on peut
pas traiter là en deux lignes un sujet
de cette importance je vous remercie
chers collègues la parole est à Philippe
B merci
madame la Présidente individuellement
nous ne pouvons les uns et les autres
qu'exprimer de la
compassion pour
les victimes
de ces décisions de l'État français mise
en œuvre avec le concours de ses
fonctionnaires pendant la période de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et pour exprimer
aussi de la
solidarité collective
nous devons déplorer ces décisions de
l'État français mais
politiquement il me semble que adopter
un amendement qui ne parle que
d'internement qui a été la première
étape d'un drame qui hélas a dépassé de
beaucoup l'internement me paraîtêtre une
erreur juridiquement et je ne veux pas
manquer l'occasion d' d'apporter sur ce
point mon d'appui à la position du
gouvernement juridiquement il a été jugé
à mainre reprise par le Conseil
constitutionnel que ce type de
disposition déclaratoire et déclamatoire
n'a rien à faire dans la loi et
historiquement surtout et là non plus je
ne veux pas manquer cette occasion de
dire que je partage intégralement le
point de vue exprimé par Madame Benbassa
historiquement nous ne sommes pas nous
Parlement
français représentation nationale
exprimant la souveraineté du peuple
français
qualifié pour
euh traiter un point d'histoire ça n'est
pas notre rôle et en empiétant sur le
travail des historiens travail
scientifique nourri par l'examen des
faits nous sortons de ce qui est la
vocation propre du Parlement et ça fait
quand même je trouve beaucoup de raison
toute tout en prenant la précaution de
dire que nous sommes les uns et et les
autres du même avis quand il s'agit
d'exprimer compassion et
solidarité ça fait beaucoup de raison
pour rejeter cette cet amendement qui
n'a pas sa place dans la loi merci cher
cèg la parole est à Madame Goulet oui
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues certains
d'entre nous sont plus ou moins sensible
et nous sommes tous solidaires et moi je
voudrais remercier nos collègues du
groupe communiste et républicain d'avoir
déposé cet amendement qui nous permet
d'évoquer en séance ce drame de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et et et de
donner
finalement un écho et et nous permettre
aussi de de voir ce qu'il est nécessaire
de faire pour que ce drame ne soit pas
oublié et je comprends très bien tout ce
que mes mes collègues ont dit je vais
rejoindre ce qu'a dit avant moi euh
Philippe Bas et Esther Benbassa euh je
pense qu'on a eu suffisamment de
problèmes avec les lois mémoriales pour
ne pas revenir euh sur sur ce sujet je
pense néanmoins qu'une résolution
pourrait être l'occasion euh de remettre
euh et de rendre aux victimes de ces
génocides tiganes euh le les honneurs
qui leur sont dusû et et je partage
comme je l'ai dit la position d''ester
Benbassa si une résolution circule dans
la maison je la signerai volontiers mais
je ne pourrai pas voter cet amendement
je vous remerci madame Goulet nous
quittons l'hémicycle du Sénat nous
reviendrons plus largement sur cette
question de l'accueil des gens du voyage
dans 24h Sénat le journal c'est à partir
de 19h mais tout de suite c'est preuve
par 3 l'émission politique de la
rédaction de Public Sénat en partenariat
avec lafp et qui reçoit ce soir Michel
Sapin le ministre du Travail à tout à
l'heure